déjà comment vous avez réagi aux propos
d'eric zemmour ce que c'est c'est quand
même vous nous en aviez parlé ici-même
c'est vrai que ça reste un traumatisme
pour vous pour tout le gouvernement et
quand vous entendez ça ça doit être
terrible pour vous non ça ça reste
d'abord un traumatisme pour pour les
français bien sûr mais non mais pour
tout le monde bien sûr mais on en parle
et vous savez d'abord le évacuons de
sujets l'un moins grave l'autre plus
graveleux promesses et que eric zemmour
ou toute personnalité ou toute personne
peut aller se recueillir rendre hommage
évidemment aux victimes des attentats et
ensuite d'une certaine manière toutes
les questions sont légitimes d'ailleurs
elles sont posés actuellement depuis des
semaines dans le cadre du procès des
attentats du 13 novembre par les avocats
des parties civiles par les
représentants des victimes par les
avocats aussi des accusés parce que nous
sommes dans un état de droit suit
d'ailleurs à une très longue enquête des
juges d'instruction ou toutes les
informations ont été données et puis la
presse le parlement les responsables
publics peuvent poser des questions et
les responsables de l'époque doivent
répondre à ces questions françois
hollande l'a fait il ya quelques jours
dans la salle d'audience et je le ferai
moi-même aussi dans quelques mois mais
après je sais bien que ça n'a plus
beaucoup d'importance aujourd'hui mais
il ya la décence j'étais marqué après
les propos d'eric zemmour phares les les
réactions des associations de victimes
parce que ce procès leur appartient mais
et les victimes n'appartiennent à aucun
responsable politique donc chercher la
polémique crée la polémique c'est une
stratégie pour être présent dans le buzz
de la delà de la campagne électorale
pour provoquer dans un moment peut-être
y a est ce qu'on peut faire du buzz et
nissan ont souvent on peut faire du buzz
d'une certaine manière surtout on le
sait bien mais sur ce sujet l'art et
séquoia autant de morts autant de
victimes autant de blessés d'abord c'est
inexact ce qui a été dit
c'est honteux alors parce qu'il ya de
gestion criminels quand il parle de
gestion
parler de gestion criminelle dire donc
que nous avons privilégié l'entrée des
migrants en europe et donc des
terroristes qui se serait où se sont
infiltrés dans les rangs des migrants au
détriment de la sécurité des français
c'est sait si on te vous savez il ya eu
encore un un attentat hier à à liverpool
sans doute tous les pays de l'europe
puis de la planète mais tous les pays de
l'europe ont été frappés seiler année
par le terrorisme c'est soit un
terrorisme nationalistes on pense aux
basques ou ou à l'irlande ce sont soit
des français qui nous frappe et qui
n'ont pas eu besoin d'aller en syrie ou
en irak on l'a vu encore ces derniers
mois soient cédés ça a été le cas de
groupes organisés par des shs manière
systématique pour frapper la france la
belgique la grande-bretagne ou
l'allemagne donc c'est un poil un d'une
très grande complexité moi je comprends
qu'on interroge l'état mais il ya une
chose que je veux dire est que je sais
c'est que ceux qui ont gouverné la
france depuis des années ont tout fait
et mettre tous les moyens sur une
situation très difficile pour protéger
les français des attentes à sion éviter
des attentats ont eu lieu si les
attentats ont lieu c'est qu'il ya eu des
failles c'est qu'il ya eu des échecs
mais dire que nous avons une
responsabilité directe d'une certaine
manière volontaire dans ce qui s'est
passé c'est insupportable et cela montre
le niveau de campagne et la violence que
veut provoquer eric zemmour dans le dans
le débat alors vous vous lui diriez quoi
eric zemmour soir si mais quand on
aspire c'est sa légitimité sans doute à
vouloir présider au destin de ce grand
pays qu'est la france qui est le pays
d'europe le plus touché par les attaques
terroristes et pourquoi
parce que nous sommes la france parce
que nous sommes une république laïque
parce qu'il les voit l'ailé loi sur
l'interdiction des signes religieux à
l'école et du voile intégral dans
l'espace public parce que nous sommes un
pays aux traditions chrétiennes parce
que nous sommes le pays où il ya la
première communauté juive d'europe parce
que nous sommes le pays où l'islam est
la deuxième religion du pays parce que
nous sommes un pays qui défend les
valeurs universelles et qui assume ses
responsabilités dans le nous sommes
attaqués par cela donc
tenir ce propos divisé m avec cette
violence de telles responsabilités sur
le président la république de l'époque
françois hollande on pourrait le faire
aussi sur nicolas sarkozy à propos de d
attente à toulouse et mon temps et je me
suis toujours refusé surtout sur les
questions du terrorisme a brisé un
moment où l'autre l'unité et à ce que
nous restions jusqu'à casser et à briser
toute tentative d' unité nationale sur
un sujet aussi grave qui est on a
attaqué la france parce que nous sommes
la république laïque parce que nous
sommes nous au pays des valeurs jeunes
et vous auriez fait autrement
aujourd'hui manuel valls ou pas du tout
sur la gestion de gestion saurait se
trouve c'est vous vous savez cyril
hanouna quand on a quand on la gouverne
et cdh ministre de l'intérieur à l'été
2012 on m'a dit qu'il y avait une
trentaine de français ou de résident en
france qui étaient partis en syrie le 19
septembre 2012 veut pas être longue bien
évidemment il ya eu une tentative
d'attentât un attentat dans une épicerie
cacher à à sarcelles et c'est ce qu'on
appelle la cellule cannes torcy
strasbourg un des terroriste a été
abattu par la police à strasbourg et
cette cellule dit j'ai déjà tout de ce
qu'elle est les formes de terrorisme
quoi et qu'on est resté les bras croisés
voulait rien fait on a préparé une
nouvelle loi sur l'enseignement
intérieur où il a renforcé le
renseignement territoriales j'ai changé
d'objectif du renseignement intérieur
j'ai fait voter j'ai présenté une loi la
première loi antiterroriste en 2012
tyran d'ailleurs les leçons de ce qui se
déplaçait à toulouse et à montauban
c'est à dire le legs que de sarkozy et
fillon est évidemment intégré ce qui
était en train de se passer on n'a pas
arrêté on savait que ce risque existait
la proclamation du califat en 2015 était
bien eu une des manifestations de la
volonté de frapper la france est
toujours parce que nous étions la france
on peut toujours faire les choses mieux
qu il ya des attentats et des morts on
vient pas sur les plateaux pour dire
c'était formidable mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que tout a été fait et
surtout le peuple français a résisté le
peuple français a résisté et saissac
oublier eric zemmour c'est que ce peuple
est grand c'est qu'il a résisté quand on
abaisse le débat banide certaine manière
on roulait pas digne de pouvoir un jour
représenter ce grand pays qu'est la
france alors jean bessière vous vous
avez entendu les propos d'eric zemmour
vous trouvez qu'il vous on pensait pas
trouver qui a été trop loin elle était
factuel tout simplement vous avez
correctement si on reprend juste en fait
la polémique si on a une aînée des
déclarations de françois hollande lui
même puisque françois hollande dit
depuis les attaques de janvier 2015 le
site 1 chaque jour nous étions sous la
menace nous savions qu'il y avait des
opérations qui se préparait des
individus qui se mêlaient aux flux de
réfugiés des chefs en syrie nous savions
tout cela donc c'est quand même le
pressenti nicotiniques de françois
hollande à une gestion criminelle de la
crise trois équipes alors il ya deux
choses d'abord il savait que dans les
colonnes de réfugiés il n'y avait non
pas des migrants qu'ils allaient
commettre des attentats encore que
c'était possible mais il pouvait aussi y
avoir des gens qui habitent et dans
certains pays européens qui était partie
il ya quelques années rejoindre le
califat et qui revenait dans le dans la
colonne de réfugiés pour préparer les
attentats et par exemple deux des trois
terroristes qui ont frappé le stade de
france venait de d'oléron emploi
l'hérault soir sans parler de la hongrie
l'allemagne dont s'est implanté ici
reste factuel l'avion messager en quoi
françois hollande a eu une gestion
criminelle de la critique ou alors tout
simplement parce vous le havre est
d'accord il a d'emblée qu'avant le les
attentats du 13 novembre la france avait
été ensanglantée en janvier de la même
année par les attentats de charlie hebdo
et de l'hyper cacher donc c'était la
première attaque terroriste d'ampleur
sur notre sol il or il aurait fallu à
tout le moins qu'on prenne la mesure du
danger or on sait que la france a pris
des mesures antiterroristes et de
mesures de protection mais 95% ou sinon
la totalité de ces mesures ont été
prises ont été prises pardon après le 13
novembre c'est à dire que après les
attentats de janvier 2015 il ya très peu
de choses finalement qui ont été bénins
c'est la première chose attendait de la
deuxième chose je finis là dessus la
preuve la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya
un principe de précaution quand on sait
au plus haut niveau de l'état qu'il y à
un risque d'infiltrations terroristes
dans les colonnes de réfugiés eh bien il
faut tout simplement tout faire pour
arrêter le flux de réfugiés en tout cas
pour mettre des contrôles drastiques à
nos frontières pas les fermer mais
renforcée votre rôle aux frontières de
manière drastique alors le risque zéro
n'existe pas évidemment mais le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'entre le
risque zéro est le fait de laisser les
frontières ouvertes il y avait des
marges appréciables de progrès on va on
va regarder d'où la polémique est partie
ta démarre à bordeaux 1-1 vendredi regza
mort était en déplacement de faire la
promo de son livre et tenir un discours
un discours dans lequel lady l'a
violemment attaqué françois hollande sur
les attentats du 13 ans en 2015 ça va
oui il savait qu'il y aurait des
terroristes il savait mais il n'a rien
fait le pouvoir était au courant du
danger
et il a préféré que des français meurent
plutôt que d'empêcher des migrants de
venir en france voilà six ans que les
visages de centaines de victimes entre
nos vies nos ennemis pensait avoir mis
la france à genoux en réalité ce que nos
ennemis ne savait pas c'est qu'ils ont
réveillé une france qui de toute son
histoire n'a jamais baissé les yeux
alors il s'est pas arrêté là eric
zemmour a réitéré ses propos et cette
fois ci c'était dont le bataclan
regardez j'ai simplement repris ce qu'il
avait dit
le président la république l'ancien
comme à publica dit lui même qu'il
savait qu'il savait que
des terroristes seraient infiltrés parmi
les migrants et qu' il n'a pas arrêter
le flot des migrants donc françois
hollande qui ne l'ignorait pas ils ne
savaient pas évidemment quelques lequel
les grandes qu'elles terroristes
auraient mais il savait qu'il y aurait
autant liste n'a pas protégé les
français et que cette île a pris une
décision absolument criminel de laisser
les laisser les frontières ouvertes
c'est quelqu'un elle exactement alors
manuel oui si je suis venu à votre
invitation ce soir quand quand votre
collaborateur map les dents dans l'après
midi c'est parce que je pense qu' il
faut expliquer aux français sur des
roches à tout ça que vous voulez vous
avoir un débat d'une très grande
complexité
la violence des mots
l'argumentation qui consiste à dire
c'est factuel mais les propos ne le sont
pas la déformation des faits parce que
tout ceci est dit d'un ton patelin ce
soit et avec une grande violence
deux fois ceci rend très difficile le
débat
il ya eu les attentats du mois de
janvier 2015 j'ai dit il ya un instant
que on avait fait voter une loi qu'on a
renforcé les services de renseignement
mais nous avons été frappés les
attentats ont été déjoués avant d'autres
ont été déjoués après d'autres ont eu
lieu et la liste est longue et ça
continue encore ce que ce que nous
savons c'est qu'en 2015
l'état islamique est en train de
s'organiser à une cellule d'ailleurs dit
d'opérations extérieures qui consiste à
projeter des
des militants vont voir des militaires
extrêmement aguerris belges français
marocains peu importe même si c'était
important pour frapper préparer à un
attentat c'est ce que les services de
renseignement extérieurs ou intérieurs
de une plus les renseignements en
général en europe ou dans le monde avec
quino coopérons les américains et les
israéliens et et nous savons aujourd'hui
jacques on découvre rien que en effet
des des terroristes s'infiltre dès le
mois de juillet dont about accompagner
du terroriste du thalys rentrer et
rentre avec d'ailleurs pour appeler des
lièvres c'est à dire des gens qui leur
ouvre le chemin pour voir si à paris ce
contrôle il passe par la hongrie il
arrive en belgique et ils ne rentreront
d'ailleurs sur le territoire national
que le 12 novembre d'ailleurs il faut
rappeler beaucoup sont belges beaucoup
sont français et ensuite ils utilisent
les papiers qui sont les leurs et au
mois d'août quand il ya le flux de
migrants qui qui balaye tous les balkans
l'autriche et c'est pour ça que angela
merkel ouvre les frontières de
l'allemagne il profite de ces moments là
je pourrais vous dire ce qui serait dû
en font une forme de cynisme d une façon
ils seraient passés d'une manière ou
d'une autre certains ont parfois été
arrêtés d'autres ont été délivrées cette
et le cas en grèce et parce que nous
savons tous ces éléments là le président
la république françois hollande vous
savez moi je peux je peux parfois être
en désaccord à françois hollande sur un
sujet on peut être en désaccord
politique mais quand il s'agit de la
france des attentats et de la guerre
qu'on nous même là je suis intransigeant
ce qui dit dégueulasse c'est indigne et
donc à ce moment-là on décide au mois de
septembre de frapper jaca pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un terroriste d'origine
francophone aussi dans la sauvagerie et
connu qui est très importante dans
l'organisation et qu'il s'agit d'eux
comme on dit de neutraliser le monde
d'ailleurs sortir à l'information et
jean yves le drian ministre de la
défense sur europe 1 s'expliquera sur ce
qui a été fait mais nous savons aussi
qu'ils about et on fera brakka parce que
nous pensons qu'ils à rabat août alors
qu'ils qu'il ait passé ses cinq ans
présent au mois au mois de juillet bon
donc c'est moi je ne nie pas la
complexité il ya des gens qui sont
passés évidemment à travers les mailles
du fait s'agit de faire du buzz il
s'agit d'être violent il s'agit de se
différencier s'agit de gêner le débat
des républicains mais utiliser cela pour
des stratégies politiques franchement
qu'on peut aller ça dégueulasse en
devient oui et puis et puis et puis
surtout venir face à ces sujets qui sont
aussi difficiles au fond on cherche à
deer valley
on n'aurait pas accepté les migrants
migron poucet d'ailleurs la france j'en
sais quelque chose n'avait absolument
pas la même position que la colle
allemagne ils ont utilisé
oui les faiblesses bien sûr qu'ils ont
utilisé les les faibles à 6 h 10 de dire
qu'il ya eu des faiblesses qui a eu des
failles qui a eu des problèmes aux
frontières bonjour la nouvelle tout le
monde tout le monde le sait les pays ils
sont passés en hongrie gens ne soient
pas de monsieur jean mary d'andernos
yeux de monsieur zemmour je pensais que
la frontière était totalement étanche il
ya les attentats en russie les attentes
en israël pour vous dire que des groupes
très déterminée sont capables de mener
des attentats et moi je souhaite c'est
que sur ces débats là on est on est
comme c'était le cas à l'assemblée
nationale à de nombreuses reprises la
capacité de s'unir ce qui n'enlève rien
du questionnement légitime mais sur ces
sujets là les questions méritent d'être
posées avec une forte en mai fiac
s'ouvre avinés et de hauteur de vue
monsieur le ministre avec tout le
respect ce premier ministre ministre
avec le tout le respect que je vous dois
pardonnez moi avec tout le respect que
je vous dois c'est en fait c'est pas ces
personnes qui dans la classe politique
qui divise les français ce qui divise
les français ce sont ceux qui les
attaquent ceux qui commettent des
attentats terroristes ceux qui font
montre de séparatisme au jour le jour
donc accusé si vous voulez quelqu'un qui
dit le réel de diviser de stigmatiser
d'attiser la haine s'est passé personne
qui est à la une attitude criminelle de
crettenand hollande c'est ce qu'ils font
les français et qui les agressent et qui
commettent des attentats terroristes il
faut se concentrer sur notre ennemi
principal ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que dans toutes les
démocraties modernes
à commencer d'ailleurs par les états
unis lorsque vous avez des attaques qui
sont les plus graves commis sur le sol
français depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale il est quand même pas
totalement illégitime qu'on interroge la
responsabilité du pouvoir politique
contra la gestion de ce qui s'est passé
ce que j'ai dit le oui mais le problème
c'est que ça pas eu lieu c'est le 11
septembre par exemple aux états unis ça
a donné lieu à toute une commission d'
enquête parlementaire etc
personne n'a dit que le président large
du président clinton et avait agi de
manière et 3 032 oui mais prône le
problème c'est que ''le interroger la
responsabilité du pouvoir politique en
france c'est comme si les politiques
devaient être exempte cela me paraît
bien gentil mais je suis au pouvoir
demander enfin je crois pouvoir dire
qu'effectivement en 2015 comme
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il y a toujours
eu deux idéologies qui se sont affrontés
en france l'idéologie qui consiste à
faire des droits de l'homme l'accueil
illimitée des migrants des étrangers etc
l'alpha et l'oméga de l'action politique
et l'autre qu'on appelle le camp de la
france où le camp national qui considère
qu'il faut avoir une optique approche
nationale des problèmes pour protéger la
france et les français je crois pouvoir
dire et je suis pas le seul en france à
le croire qu'effectivement françois
hollande appartient à une idéologie
d'ailleurs là où vous je vaux disons que
vous je vous respecte plus que françois
hollande c'est que vous vous avez
toujours nommé le mal vous avez toujours
dit et reconnu le lien qui pouvait y
avoir entre certaines immigrations et
certaines menaces qu'on pouvait avoir en
france que françois hollande a toujours
refusé
donc effectivement à ce moment-là a
triomphé l'idéologie qui consistait à
dire et d'ailleurs le cas tchenko
aujourd'hui avec la crise des migrants
est en train d'instrumentaliser cette
faiblesse de l'ordre parce qu'il sait
très bien que les migrants sont une arme
et que on accueille toujours bonjour
parce que on est inféodé eu une
idéologie humaniste au mépris de notre
propre production et c'est ce qui s'est
passé en 2015 ne vous en déplaise nous
pouvons avoir un débat sur l'immigration
sur la question de l'accueil des
réfugiés et sur le rôle de l'art c'est
pas ça le débat soit moi j'ai aucun
problème mais vous voyez bien comment le
débat glisse d'aller au fond il faut
faire le même eric zemmour a dit dans
son livre et dans plusieurs conférences
que d'une certaine manière
des slams le
laisse la main et kiki dans le box des
accusés qui étaient présents à paris le
13 novembre au soir était le bon
musulman et qu'il représentait au fond
donc c'est à chaque fois le le la même
logique c'est à dire en sourdine manière
plus ou moins clair tous les réfugiés
sont des terroristes tous les musulmans
portent cette idéologie or bien sûr que
les terroristes ont cherché à diviser la
france mais ce que ce que moi j'ai j'ai
compris en cours de ces années que je
dis très sincèrement c'est que ils n'ont
pas réussi cela c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
bien sûr qu'ils les divisions bien sûr
qu'il ya des fractures bien sûr qu'il
faut s'interroger sur les politiques
d'immigration
bien sûr qu'il ya un défi considérable
de l'islam et aux saints de l'islam et
du rapport de l'islam avec
la république cesser les sujets qu'il
faut traiter parce qu'on les a pas
traités mais parfois le pays dans cet
état mais la confusion même à la halle à
la confrontation et donc parce que moi
j'étais jeune mais aussi patriote que le
tricheur parce que je défends les
valeurs de la france parce que je
défends mon pays neutre parce que je
pense tous les jours vous l'avez ultime
donc je ne peux pas accepter qu'on mette
ce niveau de polémique c'est pour ça que
je viens c'est pour ça qu'il faut
répondre point par point et compris sur
les sur les faits il ya d'ailleurs je
rame en la pub pour le journal mais ce
soir je croyais à un article très précis
du monde par exemple qui démontre toute
la thèse selon laquelle on nous
attaquait parce que nous serions
intervenus en syrie en irak parce qu'on
aurait frappé merci c'est prenant mais
ça c'est faux
juste derrière
question monsieur le premier nommé en 30
secondes est ce que vous savez pourquoi
dans des pays comme la hongrie la
république tchèque la slovaquie la
croatie il n'y a pratiquement pas
d'attentats alors que la france est le
pays qui a eu le plus d'un an il a dit
tout à l'heure il a dit tout à l'heure
les banques ont quitté ou
de la réponse pour
mémoire
des shs dèche dans son article dans dans
son magazine de propagande dhabi de
juillet 2016 ce qu'il est important de
comprendre c'est que même si certains
sûr que votre politique extérieure est à
l'origine de notre haine cette cause est
secondaire en réalité même si vous
cessez de nous bombarder nous
continuerons à vous détester parce que
la cause principale de cette haine ne
cessera pas tant que vous n'aurez pas
embrassé l'islam merci passé parce que
nous sommes et remercie jean
de vous lire pensez pas la hongrie
banner songer à la france dans le monde
c'est pas celui là remercie